are you picking up breath of the wild on  wiiu you'll have to deal with an install  first I'm Tony and this is your  mandatory GameSpot news update the disc  version of breath of the wild requires a  three gigabyte install on Wii U it's  unclear what these install files contain  or if there will be options to increase  the install size in favor of shorter  load times by comparison the digital  versions of the game will take up 13  gigs on Wii U and 13.4 gigs on the  switch so at least you have some options  Legend of Zelda breath of the wild hits  switch and Wii U on March 3rd if you're  stuck waiting for the install then why  not check out our breakdown of Dragon  Ball super over on G s universe will  tell you everything you need to know and  for everything you need to know about  Zelda you're already in the right place  [Music]